[Music]
Christ
Christian
[Music]
welcome
fam in my head there was a much better
response when I I said that how's
everybody
doing good all right well welcome if
you're new to the table welcome we're
glad you're here if you've been here
before we're glad you're here too um we
are I'm sorry I was talking with Jesse
Watts just a while ago and he said
something to me and it threw my
whole Rhythm off so let me get back to
it on what I'm supposed to say um we we
had
a gosh I'm sorry guys Jesse you really
messed me up
man there it is there it is uh we had a
a national holiday yesterday and uh I I
want to uh say something to that if we
have any veterans in the room would you
stand up
please yeah let's give them a round of
applause all right thank you thank you
thank you for your service one thing uh
you know uh when I went through uh uh
you know I think in some degreee we're
all kind of deconstructing our faith a
little bit right and uh I grew into this
we're a peaceful people right Jesus was
a peaceful guy and so I had a hard time
with like when it came to governments
and Military and um but one thing I will
say that I always will stand up and uh
pay my respects on Veterans Day Memorial
Day because outside of all of the crazy
government decisions the person in the
heart of the person that says I will go
I will be willing to lay down something
to give of myself um I think that heart
is amazing and I will always stand up
and uh and say thank you for that so
thank you I think you're the only one
that stood up so I'm looking right at
you uh we have some events coming up uh
this week um did anybody miss the chili
cook off last
week we all did right so good news is uh
it got rescheduled so it's actually
going to be this coming Friday
the 17th thank you the 17th uh and that
is at
the see I'm trying to see if y'all knew
but also I wasn't sure so I was waiting
for a response it is at the tilford's
house and I think if we scan is it up on
the website if we scan this we can find
it and there'll be an address uh that'll
show you where to go uh also coming up
and this is really cool on January 25th
of
2024 sounds like a long way away but
it's actually just right around the
corner uh because apparently
Thanksgiving holiday week is like in a
week uh that surprised me today uh we
have something on uh it's a Thursday
evening it's a workshop and it's called
becoming a better Ally a conversation on
welcome inclusion and creating space for
all of God's beloveds uh so for info and
to register you can scan that QR code um
on the screens here uh behind me and
there's also one uh in front of
me uh so that'll be really good um
please sign up for
that and I think that's all
the announcements yes so before we uh
get into worship um if everybody will
just close their eyes for a
second um and just we're going to kind
of
reenter so just take some deep
breaths um often times I find myself uh
just go go go go go and uh I don't give
myself the time to sit in
Solace and Solace is when you can
relieve yourself of the stresses of life
and find comfort and we hope that's what
you find here at the table is a place
where you can come and find Solace where
you can
sit take off the the bags that you're
carrying
and sit with like like people who love
you and want to lift you
up and as the Band Stars playing some
music um I wanted us to think
about why is
it that we
love
God and how is it that I portray that to
the people around
me
to continue um reflecting on that
question and as we go into this first
song you guys can stand with us if you
would like sing along um we're basically
singing the words of Psalm 116 together
um so we just invite you guys to join in
and it's the it's a Psalm about loving
the Lord and trusting him um running
after him so you guys join
us in just a moment you guys can join
[Music]
us I love you
Lord you have delivered me
I Love You
Lord you have delivered my
soul my Fe from stumbling I will walk in
the of Liv
Soul stumbling I will walk in the land
of the living
[Music]
let's sing that again I love you
Lord I love you
Lord you have delivered
me I Love You
Lord you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the Liv my soul from my
feet from stumbling I will walk in the
land of the
living
[Music]
sing I Will
Bless I Will Bless You Lord For You
Heard My Cry I reached out my hand and
you save my life I will bless you Lord
for you heard my ple and the god of
Heaven turn his to me I will bless you
Lord for
amending love for your grace and mercy
raining down from above I Will Bless You
Lord till the very end I will call on
you as long as
I I love you Lord
for you have delivered
me I love you
Lord you have delivered my soul from
Death my Fe from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the of the
[Music]
Liv all right we're going to dismiss our
kids to their classrooms so um second
through sixth are over here and four
years through first grade is over to my
left and if you have young toddlers or
babies they're back in the hall way o
are they with the flood is that room
where are babies and toddlers they're in
here thanks
Kelly also thank you very much to Kelly
and El I think August and
Katie um Casey Nancy birie yes thank you
guys for serving our kids this week we
love you very
much we're going to transition into the
prayers of the
people and um if this is your first time
with us this is a a moment where we get
to hold up the things that we're
carrying on our hearts up before God
together believing that he's here with
us that he cares about what we care
about um so I just invite you guys to
join us we're going to read it aloud
together and then we'll pause for a
moment during the prayer um for you to
say a name or a situation that's on your
heart on your mind um and we'll say
those out loud and then we'll finish the
prayer together so um Jes Jesus for the
city of saxi Texas and for every city
and community and all who live in them
we pray to you for the Good Earth you
have given us and the wisdom and the
will to conserve it we pray to you for
the old and the sick for the Widow and
orphan for the injured and suffering we
pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you for the vulnerable the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have
light life and light I'm sorry healing
and hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
[Music]
amen
sping out of control I feel it losing my
defenses no it's not easy letting go
with trusting you
[Music]
different all this I know that all
you've said you got it no it's not easy
let go when trusting
you so I will
stop rest in your goodness I know you
only is my
confidence I will
stop bre rest here in your goodness I
know you won't leave it's my
[Music]
confence sing spinning spinning out of
control I feel it losing my
defenses no it's not easy letting go and
trusting
[Music]
you all this I know God oh you said you
got it no it's not easy let go and trus
in
you so I was
stop I will stop Brea rest here in your
goodness I know you
only my
confidence I will stop Brea rest here in
your goodness I know you won leave it's
my confidence I will stop I will stop
Brea rest here in your goodness I know
you won't leave it's my confidence oh I
will stop Brea rest you in your goodness
I know you all it's my
confidence here I am in the B of your
head nothing can take me away nothing
can take me away
here I am in the of your head nothing
can take me away nothing can take me
[Music]
away not a or a death not a light inside
my head not a fear or offense nothing
can take
away not a hide or a death not a lie
inside my head not a fear or offense
nothing can take me
away not a hide or a death not a lie
inside my head not a fear or offense
nothing can take me away oh not a hide
or a dead not a lie inside my head not a
fear or renge nothing can take you
away nothing can take you in nothing
Take Me Away nothing can take me away
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away nothing can take me away
nothing can take me
away here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing nothing
can take me
away here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away one more time here I am in
the of your head nothing can take me
away nothing can take me away here right
in the of your head nothing can take me
away nothing can take me away it's my
confidence it's my
confidence it's my confidence it's my
confidence
[Music]
for everyone
born a place at the
table to everyone
born clean water and
bread a shelter a
space a safe place for
growing for everyone
born a star
overhead and God will Delight when we
are
creators of Justice
and
joy
compassion and peace and God will
Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
[Music]
joy
for woman and
man a place at the
table revising the
RO deciding the
share with wisdom and
Grace dividing the
power for genders
diverse a system that's f
and God will Delight when we are
creators of justice and
joy
compassion and peace and God will
Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
[Music]
joy
Justice and
joy for everyone
born a place at the
table a covenant
shared a
welcoming
space a rainbow of race of gender and
color
for gay and for
straight a chalice of
Grace and God will Delight when we are
creators of Justice
enjy
compassion and peace and God will
Delight when we are
creators of just
justice justice and
joy Justice and
[Music]
joy Oh How He Loves
Us oh Oh How He Loves
[Music]
Us
and how he loves us
so Oh How He Loves
Us how he loves us
[Music]
so
How He
Loves he loves us
Oh How He Loves Us Oh How He Loves Us Oh
How He
Loves He Loves Us Oh How He Loves Us Oh
How He Loves Us Oh How He
Loves
[Music]
Love How He Loves
Us How He Loves Us How He Loves Us
[Music]
so How He Loves
Us Oh How He Loves
Us How He Loves
Us God I'm just reminded
tonight that we we don't have to earn
your
[Music]
love it's not based on our performance
or our
qualifications it's not based on our
track record or our
past it's not based on our
intelligence how likable we
[Music]
are but you created us and you said that
it was
[Music]
good
you have always loved
us and what could separate us from the
love of
God could height or
depth could light or
[Music]
darkness no your love is greater than
all
things
and at the end of the day love
wins your love has made a
way thank you for being a God that's
full of love full of compassion full of
justice and
truth thank you that we can sink
ourselves into you and know that you
will
hold that you are not turning your back
that you're not running
away you are not distant you are not far
off you are here you are in
us and you are the one that will
continue to write this story that will
continue to walk us through the high
times and the low times God you will be
here you are our
[Music]
constant and we want to believe that
with all that we
are your love is
enough it will see us
[Music]
through we hold on to that tonight
God it's in Jesus name
amen will you guys turn to the people
around you and welcome them say hello
and then will get us started on our
message
well Grace and peace it is so good to be
with you all so good and uh my name is
Brett and it's a a joy to be with you a
joy to welcome you and as always that
includes those joining us online y'all
are not forgotten and um anyone here who
is new tonight uh thank you for being
here I know it's not a small thing to
walk through those doors coming into a
strange place and you know it's like
maybe a a a friend told you don't worry
they're nice you know but still your
heart's like a little bit you know and
so we're just yeah we're really really
glad that that you're here and um hope
you can just I don't know sense the the
welcome the love of of Christ um so we
are uh wrapping up a Series tonight it's
been a fun one uh it's titled the Bible
doesn't say that and uh we've just been
working through these little like turns
of phrase I've called them like um
bumper sticker theology like these
little phrases that are kind of most of
them are in the church some that are
have made their way to the broader
culture um but they're just these little
you know these little cliches mostly um
that we've you know we've kind of seen
they have uh I'd say if I've kind of
learned anything from these most of them
honestly we've been quite hard on um but
if I've learned anything I would say
I've kind of learned some discernment
like that's often what's needed when
people use these little turns of phrase
and it's like they're catchy they're
memorable um but we need some
discernment in that moment to be like is
that true you know I mean a is that even
in the scriptures you know which as
we've seen like none of these are even
they sound like it right it's sort of
like think that's from the Bible you
nope um so there's a lot of yeah there's
a lot of discernment kind of needed um
with these and I think we've kind of got
to to learn to um eat the meat and spit
out the bones to use the weird fish
metaphor um you know to to kind of
discern what's good here if anything and
then what is just like Let it go you
know um so there's been a lot of a lot
of Letting Go in the series um and so
our our final little phrase tonight that
we're going to be working through
is uh forgive and
forget uh this is um this is a popular
one for sure in Christian circles and
you know honestly if you're looking for
like just some good resources like a
Christian writer who's thinking through
forgiveness um you can do no better than
mirav Vol um I know that's quite uh that
name he's as you can tell from from his
name uh not from the US um actually I'll
get into a story in a moment but I I
need a name that I've drawn pretty
heavily from his book um the end of
memory remembering rightly in a violent
world and the reason wul writes so
powerfully on um
forgiveness is um because of his his
history so he was um born in 1956 in
Croatia so because of this he lived
through the Yugoslav wars um which raged
there throughout like the
1990s um and it was like I mean like all
wars it was awful there was genocide
there was widespread ethnic cleansing um
wulfe then right he's born in the 56 so
he's in kind of his 30s you know in in
the 90s so he was pastoring by then he
was a theologian though I think not
super well known at that point um so
he's pastoring and like literally the
the doors or the the wars like on his
doorstep his parishioners like some of
them were killed um tortured his own
father was tortured um Vol himself
underwent like intense um he called
intense interrogation sort of flirting
with torture but like maybe not quite to
that level but uh so he basically he
came away from that
experience um and this is why I think
he's such a good writer on it because
it's just not like cliche kind of easy
you know I think it's very easy even for
pastors to be like hey just forgive
we're Christians we just forgive and
that's who we are you know and it's like
yeah but there's got to be a certain
empathy with like the cost the you know
you know what I'm saying like this is
weighty stuff I mean I get there's like
sometimes easy things to forgive and you
know fair enough like okay let's forgive
and forget you know move on it's like
that's dumb but we're talking about the
weighty things and that's what vul
speaks to so well because he came away
from that experience like knowing as a
Christian yes forgiveness is very
important but because he was just face
to face with evil and like um just the
horrors of life he really um said like
okay how what does it mean to
forgive how do I forgive and how do I do
that well um in light of all I've been
through and perhaps you can you maybe
you haven't lived through like war or
genocide but you've you've lived through
your own experiences and maybe you've
gone through things where you're like
yeah I'm not sure how I'm getting beyond
that and maybe someone when they put
this kind of phrase in your your face
like hey well forgive and forget you
know it just there's something in you
that kind of Rises up like oh I'll tell
you about forget you know uh and and I
think yeah this is is there's a lot here
to to kind of unpack and something he
writes about so powerly um that ties
directly into our theme which is why I
immediately thought of Wulf when I heard
you know I was thinking about this this
phrase forgive and forget um he writes
about easy
forgetfulness easy forgetfulness so he
doesn't actually use the phrase forgive
and forget instead he talks about this
easy forgetfulness um he says you know
like obviously when there's like a deep
pain or hurt or trauma in our life
um sometimes we kind of Swing which
we'll get to later kind of a you know oh
you think I'm going to forget you know
forget about it you know I'm not doing
that um but of sometimes it's the
reverse though it's the sort of forgive
and forget thing it's like it's sort of
a um hey let's just move
on let's just move on
and that's often I think if I had to
kind of get it the spirit of forgive and
forget and why it kind of rubs us wrong
um because I mean in essence it could be
beautiful like wow imagine you could so
thoroughly forgive that you literally
forget the thing happen like I get see
like wow that like what a Grace and a
gift that would be you know kind of a
weird thing to put on people like that's
I don't know how you make yourself
forget anything you know um but I can
see the beauty in it but but where the
danger is is when it's deployed in this
way you know like it's almost like hey
um you just just forgive and forget move
move on let it go it's almost like a
christianized version of you know get
over
it uh and that it just seems really
problematic there's uh one way like a
practical way I think this this plays
out in um some like families is in the
idea of uh like family
secrets if you were raised with a family
that had like Family secret you know
these kind of weird things that it's
like but that like really happened uh
you know whether it was to you or
significant you know or just people that
you love in the family or what or maybe
even collectively you went through a
thing you know but it was like the pain
was so much uh and people were so kind
of emotionally uncomfortable or just for
whatever reason it became this weird
thing of we just don't talk about
that at all and it's weird we don't even
name that we're not going to talk about
it right like that even that
conversation didn't happen it's just
kind of like we just don't you um what
is that I think that's a perfect example
of an easy forgetfulness like you could
even imagine maybe a Christian family
kind of
rationalizing that Family secret and
that inability to like talk it through
and process and you know with well well
we just forgive and forget you know
that's isn't that what Jesus as the
Bible says you know uh yeah we need to
we need to re rethink this and and so to
this idea of easy forgetfulness um Mira
wolf he says
no no uh and actually as we turn to the
scriptures uh we see these themes of
remembrance coming up over and over and
over again in fact there's like two you
might even call them like core memories
of the people of God in the Bible one
Old Testament one New Testament um both
of them these kind of
traumatic
events and both of
them the Lord actually instructs people
to do what
remember well look that the two I have
in mind is The Exodus and the
crucifixion so with the Exodus this is
um from Deuteronomy 24 4:
18 uh writes
remember that you were slaves in Egypt
and the Lord your God redeemed you from
there in fact you can find Like A
variation of this exact phrase the
statement um in Deuteronomy um chapter 5
chapter 15 and then of course here in 24
you can also find it in Exodus 12 and
then Exodus 20 and then again in Exodus
23 so it's like this kind of recurring
instruction um to remember and I mean in
light of like you kind of can see what
he's in inviting them to to remember
right like I mean on the one hand you
could say well it's a good thing right
the ending redeemed you from there and
yes that's true you know I mean it's not
like just all bad or something like
there is a a goodness to it and yet
what's the redeemed you from where you
know it's not redeemed you from that
place that we do not speak of you know
no like
it's remember you were slaves in Egypt
remember so it's it's not a kind of
wiping away you know or I can even
imagine someone might think well of
anything that God would be like hey you
know what forget forget just move on
we're just you know that that was over
and we're never going to speak of it
again it was horrible everyone knows
it's horrible let's move on we be this
and yet no in fact there is a um a
recurring liturgy and this annual series
of Feasts that the Jewish people to this
day um Orthodox Jews continue to
remember it's called the Passover and
it's this series of kind of meals where
they do what
remember like literally they played out
year after year remembering then of
course we um come to the New Testament
uh talk about a trauma talk about a
moment of grief and
loss and pain pain and yes again like
The Exodus there is good um where there
it ends in Resurrection but of course
the crucifixion like oh my gosh what
what an awful thing to undergo and so
you again you might imagine that like
well what what Christians would do is
they would just kind of focus on the
resurrection and never talk about the
crucifixion again you know that trauma
uh but that's not not the tradition and
and you can see that even from the very
earliest uh days of the Christian church
this is from 1 Corinthians chap 11
verses 23-
2 uh Paul writes for I received from the
Lord what I also passed on to you the
Lord Jesus on the night he was betrayed
took bread and when he had given thanks
he broke it and he said this is my body
which is for you do this in what
remembrance
remembrance remembrance and you think of
it every single week we'll do it in just
a few minutes right like we come forward
to receive the body the blood of Christ
like to do what to remember again do
this in remembrance of me in the same
way after separ he took the cup saying
this cup is the New Covenant in my blood
do this whenever you drink it in
remebrance of me so far from a kind of
forgive and forget move on we're the
forgiving people we're the Christian
people so we just you uh you actually
find this kind of um kind of sober
remembering a
remembering now um as I hinted at
earlier though you could
imagine uh that we don't even have to
imagine you know you've seen the world
you know how the pendulum can swing can
it not like from on the one hand one
coping mechanism m is let's just move on
forgive and forget you know it's kind of
easy forgetfulness the other coping
mechanism is oh yes I love this sermon
never forget oh we will not be forget
you know like you can imagine that kind
like it's this sort of um I mean the
probably the the watch word here would
be
Vengeance it's a kind of
impassioned um a an angry not not just
even angry like a a furious kind of
never we will never
forget um maybe some of you can relate
to that maybe depending on personalities
right we we lean towards one of these
some of us are just let's just move on
and be friends why can't we just be
friends you know and then others are
like oh Justice will be served you know
um and this is this is where you know
where it goes um and so wul even names
this he says yeah the the never forget
mindset can have kind of its own um its
own troubles its own shadow sides I was
thinking of like examples of this in
kind of culture um so many of Quinton
Tarantino's films came to mind he he
adores these Revenge fantasies I
remember I had um one year this is
probably good eight years ago so I was
sick and I was like you I was like going
to watch Netflix you know what are you
going to do when you're sick sick you
know and so I remember I saw I was like
oh Kill Bill I've heard of this I've
never seen it it's Taren you know he's
good and I watched if you've seen I mean
I'm not actually suggesting you see this
it's the most horrifically tragically
violent movie I've ever seen there must
be 5,000 people that die in this film I
mean it's in it is crazy um but the
whole I mean there's Kill Bill one and
there's Kill Bill two it's the same
story though you know it's just it's
just
Vengeance it's just like Bill was bad
did a bad thing to her and so she's
going to get him and but in between her
and him are like many thousands of
people and so they all have to die you
know um or another this would be a more
uh well and there's like in glorious
Pastor I mean there's just all he just
he loves all these right um I was
thinking of a lighter example though
would be um Princess Bride and the
Spaniard you know uh what's the his
famous my name you guys
say you kill my father prepared to die
yes all of you if you were children of
the what is it 80s 90s or parents
raising children I don't know you might
maybe I don't know if that kind of
carried on maybe others know um right
now it's cute like in a film you know
mean we watch whatever this movie and
it's sort of like and it feels good even
you know there is something even in
Tarantino's violence like the Revenge
fantasies and it just sort of like yes
you know over there's the neig toy and
we're like yeah Vengeance Vengeance you
know just it feels nice you know um but
of course like in real
life uh it it doesn't go so well does it
I mean you think of like ano mto's
actual life his whole life was just
swallowed up in this journey to
kill you know like you can see where in
the real world um that
gets destructive like that that um we
looked at this passage last week um
Jesus said what what good is it if you
gain the whole
world um in this context we might say
you know what good is that you get all
the
Vengeance you could ever want on
everyone that did you wrong and yet
Jesus says what good is it though if you
get all that but in the end you lose
your soul which I don't just interpret
as like you know but and then at the end
of your days you go to the bad place you
know I I think losing the losing the
soul happens right here right now every
day
Vengeance it eats Us
Alive
erods erodes Grace
erodes compassion before we know it like
love can find no room in our
hearts so this is kind of the the
struggle right what do we do we have
easy
forgetfulness we have a bitter you know
never for what do we do well following
the scriptures um I think we kind of sum
it up like this the antidote to forgive
and forget is not a bitter never forget
but the ongoing work of remembering
rightly in other words
remembering but
without that edge without that Spirit of
retaliation and vengeance
and bitterness that erodes the soul it's
like a it's like a it's we're
remembering but without the
resentment and as vul goes on to to name
it's really the crucifixion specifically
that models such a
powerful um I mean it just gives us such
a powerful picture of exactly what
that's like I mean right we worship the
Jesus who hung on the cross and said
literally in moment father forgive them
they do not know what they are
doing um there's a quote from wul it's a
little bit dense but I'll sum it up
afterwards um but it's I think really
insightful he says through my memory of
the passion he's thinking here the
crucifixion God can purify my memory of
wrong suffered because my
identity stems neither from the
wrongdoing done to me
which would require the Perpetual
accusation of my wrongdoer even if it's
just in my mind um nor from my own false
innocence which would lead me to
illegitimate
self-justification I know that's that's
a mouthful so in other words I think
what he's naming is when we look at the
cross what do we see Jesus
forgiving
them whoever them
is and me
and that's the trick he's forgiving them
and me this is
unsettling correct like it's it's
destabilizing de
centering and and that's the power of it
that's the beauty of it it's almost this
um this image this story this truth that
that breaks us out of the ruts we fall
in either a kind of easy
forgetfulness or a bitter pursuit of
lifelong
Vengeance it it breaks us out and
suddenly we can find our s remembering
rightly uh the key as both says the key
is to remember and to behold what God on
the cross has done for sinful humanity
and for me I really like that word
behold I'll probably be preaching on it
in future um weeks to behold what's
behold it's sort of a um a meditative a
kind of contemplative posture where we
we don't just I don't know think of the
Cross like when we're at church or on
Good Friday or what you know but but we
take some time to behold Jesus on the
cross to see Jesus forgiving me and them
and
suddenly something in US begins to shift
the Holy Spirit begins to do her work in
our hearts and Minds like how does it
happen I don't know there's tremendous
mystery to the human mind and soul um
all I know is when we commit ourselves
to the process and by the way it is a
process if kind of what you're pulling
from this message is like you know if
you just meditate once upon the cross
well then you shall forgive and it's no
problem at all you know like no this is
this is going to be a process but as we
do that things begin to shift in our our
heart and our mind suddenly the way we
remember things
changes our instincts to kind of slip
into an easy forgetfulness or an easy
bitterness begins to
shift and with it our remembering shifts
and then the way we tell the story
begins to change that's key
you often know to what degree kind of
forgiveness by Grace has found you by
how you tell the
story we have uh this welcome to the
table class we haven't had one in a few
months we need another one we'll have
one actually in December um but it's
sort of our like new members class and
not sort of it is our new members class
uh and I uh I teach that and the first
time we're going to have one I was
writing like the general script you know
like what what do we want to cover and
all and I realized we need to start with
the
story the story of the
table where where do we come
from and the first time I went to do
that I
realized oh
no um I don't I don't know how to do
that um and what I was wrestling with
was everything we we've been talking
about tonight you see the table did not
just drop from the
heavens uh did not come from nowhere uh
many of I know in talking with with you
um many of you find a certain life here
there's there's certain values our
values thoughtful inclusive eclectic
communal vulnerable um kind of our way
of being Church there's certain things
you you appreciate you know um the truth
is many not all but many of those things
not just me um many of our leaders and
the folks who helped start this
community gleaned
those from our previous Church they were
mentors um they were in some cases
family literal family
members
and in January 2017 we launched a
different
church and and um there's a whole
backstory there you want the long
version you can take him out for coffee
or something you know or we're at edgy
Church take me out for a beer I don't
know whatever
um you know that is such a classic thing
you're gonna hang out with the pastor at
the coffee shop and is so classic
um but um we were GNA you know launch
this community and what was
so what ended up happening was uh gay
and lesbian folks began to attend and
long story short over time it became a
thing in the community not big and
dramatic not like ugly but you know but
just sort of uncomfortable for everyone
it wasn't an open and affirming Church
though we could like um lgbtq folks
could not fully participate in the life
of the church and
eventually myself others reached a point
where we just knew like we we just
couldn't continue that church went on
for almost three years
we just couldn't it was beautiful it was
like a beautiful community in so many
ways but I just knew like I can't I just
felt um myself others felt we weren't in
Integrity to continue to exclude you
know in that way um and it's at this
point that the telling of the story
matters because I think it's neither
true that on the one hand though I'm
tempted to tell the story in this way
like and then they heartlessly kicked us
out you know um or I can imagine them
telling the story you know and then in
willful
Rebellion BR LED those people astray you
know
um you know but honestly neither of
those tellings really resonates with me
and the longer I
Journey the more I'm able to tell a
different
story one where the truth is we try
tried both of us all of us like our
Elder team met with their Elder team for
like months like we we tried and when we
were even hoping for kind of a middle
way maybe we could like thread the
needle and like still be true to kind of
what we felt the Lord's saying and they
could you know maybe we could do start
the needle you know and it just didn't
work out we just couldn't we couldn't
figure it out maybe other churches can
figure it out we just we
couldn't um and so we said goodbye the
truth is I still um I still missed them
I still miss them and I know they miss
me and us um I pray for them I know they
pray for us and maybe for various
[Laughter]
reasons but you know that's the
beauty that's the beauty is I think God
meets Us in the messiness aren't so many
of our stories like just it's just messy
messy it's just messy and I think this
is where we have to bring our full
selves without slipping into one of the
two ruts you know because it' be easy to
be like hey you know don't worry about
the past it's great we're great with
that church they're great it's all good
it's all good you know it's like what
you know or a kind of bitter never for
you know but no that's the trick right
that's the trick to Remember to Remember
rightly um so I wonder what it's for you
you know you know maybe for some of you
it is church kind of background stuff
maybe it's like completely other things
um I invite you I encourage us to be a
community that begins to behold begins
to behold Jesus on the cross sees Jesus
forgiving them and us and from
that oh just praise for the grace that
the Holy Spirit can fill us that the
spirit of forgiveness can find us in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit amen
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord
tonight
um it's very fitting I think that we
have communion you know uh because this
is our chance to come forward to receive
the body the blood of Jesus the
forgiving one the one who's forgiven us
and so I encourage you as you come
forward um you might I want you to just
like bring with you whatever burden
maybe it's a person a situation you just
bring them with you into this experience
I'm not saying to force anything or like
and there forgive and you'll forever be
set free you know but just bring them
with you and just welcome Christ into
that situation into that
relationship and um and I trust that as
you take in the body and blood of Jesus
that something will begin begin to shift
no matter how small so the way we'll um
do this tonight is we will start um
we'll just kind of go like row by row
and kind of work our way backwards that
way we don't get like an impossibly long
you know line back here um we practice
what's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and something in you
wants to participate then you are free
to do that regardless of your like
denomination or your exact theology or
you know whatever if you're here and you
want to connect with Jesus then you are
welcome to do that
um you should know that the red is wine
the white is grape juice and um finally
you can just partake whenever you'd like
no one will lead you through the exact
moment some people take it right away
others return to their seats and kind of
prayerfully um partake there so this is
the table not of the
church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long you
who have tried to follow and you who
have
failed come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
that was very beautiful and I think very
relatable to a lot of us and and thank
you um to the ushers as well for uh
offering us communion um I wanted to
just invite you into this song by trying
to make it a little relatable um about
forgiveness and I think sometimes it's
easy to see people up here appearing to
think that we're somehow better or
Holier have our lives figured out and
everything is tighten up in a bow and
it's not not really like that a lot um
during the preparation for this song
during the week um I realized that
there's like one person in my life who I
have not forgiven and and that's my dad
and I sat with that for a while and
um there was a line at the end of the
song um as I had those thoughts I was
thinking about that where he says just
give it time just give it time and um I
think that that showed me that
forgiveness is not a process that can be
forced it's it's a process that has to
be developed and it can take a long time
so I just want to encourage you that you
know if there is someone or a situation
that you haven't forgiven yet give
yourself a little kindness and validate
the hurt that you went through and give
yourself time to forgive um open up to
the process and knowing it may take a
while like Brett message meant um having
our eyes focused on Christ is is what I
try to think about having my eyes and my
hope my trajectory being upwards towards
hoping for forgiveness and opening up to
that possibility um so I just want to
encourage you all to think about about
that and to give yourselves time to
forgive if you need to um and just to
reflect on these words throughout the
rest of your day Gary's going to lead us
now and yeah just taking these
[Music]
wordss I tried to hold you like a secret
wouldn't let go I wouldn't let
[Music]
go deep down I knew I couldn't keep it
wouldn't you
know wouldn't you
know sometimes I climb to watch the sun
lose to the
Rain lose to the
rain I stood there waiting at your
doorstep you never came you never
came oh I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive you I even if I don't know
how oh I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive you I I will come to lay it all
[Music]
down
you wouldn't stop to let me help you you
had to go you had to
go so many things I want to tell you
you'll never know you'll never
know but I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive you I even if I don't know how
but I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive you I I will come to lay it all
down oh I will come to lay it all
[Music]
down a friend ran into you on
Friday fine you're doing
fine says I'm just stuck inside the
replay just give it time just give it
time I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive you I even if I don't know
[Music]
how I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive you I will come to lay it all
down I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive
you even if I don't know
how I forgive you I forgive you I
forgive
you I will come to lay it all
down oh I will come to lay it all
[Music]
down
thanks
guys man thank you so much Gary and kale
that was awesome love that uh thank you
for joining us tonight uh if you're new
here there's a small table out in the
forer that we'd love for you to fill out
some
information um it's not so that we can
sell it it's because we want to follow
up with
you and uh in in the least we just want
to say thank you for coming uh I there's
so many faces in here right now that I
haven't seen so uh fill that card out
you can also scan the QR code um and
that will take you to the website I
believe and it'll have information you
can fill out something online as well um
so thank you uh for being here
also at the table we are committed to a
Christ centered uh inclusive community
uh to creating a Christ centered
inclusive community and it turns out
that takes
money uh so if you feel inclined to uh
donate or uh or uh uh uh give money to
this this commitment of ours to be a
Christ centered uh inclusive community
uh you can also scan this code on the
screen and it'll show you how to do that
um and uh but we just appreciate you
being here um so thank you for
that the announcements from before this
Friday the chili cook off and January
25th uh we have that uh we a
seminar Workshop thank you yes we are
going to do work at that uh it's not a
seminar that you listen to It's a
workshop we get better um so thank you
for that uh one thing I did not memorize
is the blessing that I want to send
everybody out with um so if you could
stand uh if you'd like you know I'm not
going to force
you uh and then if you if you want you
can open your hands as you're receiving
a blessing uh for us to go into the
week get my contacts right
here stand guys I'm sorry my eyes
are contacts are
readjusting this was not rehearsed
all right you are a child of God you are
a child of God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst day so
as you go into your week ahead with its
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed have
a good week and we hope to see you back
here next
[Music]
Sunday